there's no joy without pain there's no
sunshine without rain you need up and
down this is how the world works
as a man you must build yourself
and i agree that society puts huge
pressure on men and it's time for men to
perform as a man you either perform or
you don't it's there's no there's no
safety net the men who say i can't feel
like it
cannot compete with the men who do not
say that and it's player versus player
the man who goes to the gym every single
day regardless of how he feels will
always beat the man who goes to the gym
when he feels like going to the gym and
it's player versus player a good man
controls himself
i have absolute self-control
emotional control is absolutely and
utterly important as a man you need to
understand as a man there are certain
principles under which you act
regardless of how you feel bam i can
wake up in a terrible mood i can wake up
sad i can ache i can have a busy day
stressed etc i will complete the same
tasks as if i woke up in a fantastic
mood i'll do the same things because how
i feel has no bearing on the things i'm
going to do with my day because i have
duty to myself there is no light without
dark you will not appreciate your
six-pack unless you didn't have one and
you had to earn it
that's how the world works so when i
talk to these dudes like oh but it's you
know what tate yeah i agree but you know
it's hard it's hard of course it is it's
supposed to be
and if you're not cut out for it then
[ __ ] off and live a normal existence and
die sit there letting other men enjoy
the spoils of being a man and can die if
that's what you want to do is just sit
there and exist and then be fade into
history unremembered
that's your decision if you want to
level up your character then you need to
get out here and do it you need to be
around brave men you need to get some
balls you need to get your network
together you need to be paying attention
listen to the truth humble yourself stop
sitting there with an ego that's the
game but i made myself this way i wasn't
born this way i absolutely not really
made myself this way and any single one
of you men out here can do the same
thing i was always looking for i
wouldn't say happiness or contentment
but i was always looking to try and
break out of the nine to five just the
normal monotony of day-to-day life i
think that men
have a very unique life path and it's
very difficult to try and achieve
status as a man it's not easy to stand
out from the crowd and even what women
expect of an important man you need to
be smart charismatic intelligent strong
have a nice car nice apartment good
network good friends you need to be able
to handle stress you need to be
competent there's so many things you
need to be able to do it's difficult for
a young man to even have all these
things you need to start leveling up
your mentality your spirituality you
need to level up your physicality
physicality there's so many different
ways you can level up like a video game
character right once you have all the
unlimited money you can then start
ticking all the stacks boxes knowledge
when guys take me okay well how do i
make women respect me or so how do you
respect yourself that's the first thing
no one's gonna respect you you don't
respect yourself do other men respect
you like how do you act in a way that
commands respect from anybody i say look
if you focus on yourself and make
yourself be who you are being a
high-value male women will detect it and
they won't be so difficult for you you
have to respect yourself first and how
does how does a woman respect a man when
she sees he respects himself and other
men respect you need to understand that
the world you live in as a man in my
personal view has been very purposefully
constructed and it's been constructed in
a way to destroy your masculine power
and the future of the world especially
in the west is a further encroachment on
your sovereign ability your sovereign
thoughts your base instincts the things
that make you happy absolutely nobody is
concerned with male happiness on any
level they don't want you to be happy
they want you to be miserable a
miserable slave and a tax bracket and
you have to understand this and the only
way you can combat against it is to take
significant action you have to take
significant action you have to use the
internet it's the tool they're using the
internet it's the tool they're using to
brainwash the messes you need to combat
it and use their own tool against them
to seek out the kind of information
knowledge and friends that you need to
have around you you are going to be the
sum of the five people you spend the
most time with so that if everyone
understands that
as an intelligent person you're going to
be extremely careful and you're going to
create heavily the five people you hang
around with so you need to be aware of
what's happening around you and you need
to create for yourself a social network
of people who understand that and are
doing their best to combat that that is
the most basic imperative of the
masculine
frame which has been destroyed in real
time
they are trying to convince you that you
should act how you feel you should show
more of your feelings if you feel this
way you should show it if you want to
cry cry look i have no problem with guys
crying what i'm saying is the reason
they're trying to bring out emotionality
in you is most of the time you don't
feel like doing the things you're
supposed to do
but the true masculine frame throughout
history was doing the things they didn't
want to do but they knew they had to do
because they had honor and duty when you
remove
self-control from men not only do you
get emasculated weak men but what you
also get is very dangerous men there are
actually far less genuinely high value
men than there are pretty girls you can
go to any club in any country in the
world i've been to 72 countries you can
go to any club in any country in the
world and see pretty girls if you're
going to find a young in shape smart
tall
intelligent rich man it's extremely
difficult to find and that man has
options he has more options than a
beautiful girl and i'll tell you
something there's always been a large
proportion of men in the world who made
the choice to stay where they are
and life for them wasn't that bad but as
as we reach the future and as as time
goes on you're going to notice now that
the people who don't chase
having a masculine network if they're
not going to be excellent upon
themselves and they're not going to be
plugged into a serious circle of of
achievers their life's going to become
terrible you could just be a normal dude
and your life really wasn't that bad
but now we live in a situation where you
just can't just be a normal dude anymore
being a normal dude is no longer an
option so as a man you have to be doing
something to try and improve your status
there's lots of different ways to do it
right but if you're a man with truly no
status in society now it's hard yeah
it's really hard so you have to
understand that as a man you gotta gear
your life in a certain way one of the
easiest ways to get status is who you
know right a lot of it's networking and
if you know the right people you can get
some statements at least on them to some
degree every single man on earth with
enough work can become one that's the
counter side right so there is there is
hope at the end of the tunnel but you
gotta get up and do it you know what i
truly think a high value man is
okay it's a few things right so there's
the obvious evolutionary triggers the
easiest way to be a high-value man is a
man who's capable of violence we look at
it from a biological trigger it doesn't
matter if he's got muscles or he's big
or he's tall whatever women understand
from a biological perspective they like
a man who can fight yeah it doesn't
matter if your man had money a ferrari
everything but if you knew for a fact if
any dude stepped to him he'd get sparked
you wouldn't want it right so that's the
first thing we're suffering from
cowardice you talk about all the
problems in the world it's easy to talk
about them all but you can narrow them
all down to the exact same thing
cowardice masculine cowardice all of it
all of this is masculine cowardice
that's all it is you're not gonna be
able to imitate being a g you have to go
out there and you have to suffer as a
man you gotta go through trauma to be a
g as a man too many dudes out here are
trying to imitate that's what all this
is you're talking about game you're
trying to be something you're not the
real game is to be the man that's a game
as a man you need to go through trauma
you need to go through difficult periods
you need to go through things which are
extremely uncomfortable to become any
kind of man of value every single woman
on this panel if you were to ask her to
describe the kind of man she wants she
would describe a man who she thinks
makes her feel safe who is dominating
who is smart who is charismatic who is
interesting etc you cannot be all of
those things by accident any man who
grows up with a very very easy life who
never goes through anything who's born
with a silver spoon in his mouth is the
exact kind of punk which these women
don't want to touch right
as a man you need to suffer and you will
survive and you need to internalize it
not become a weirdo accept that the
traumas was going to make you strong
enough to become the kind of man that's
respected by society and you use it for
your own advantage as a man if you have
not been through extremely difficult
processes you're never going to be a
high value man so when you ask me that
question the answer is an answer you're
not hoping for because likely you've
been avoiding trauma your whole life
life is difficult everyone has bad news
all the time things happen to people and
and things are going to happen to
everyone and even if you live the
perfect life you're still going to have
bad experiences because everything's
relative when people talk about oh toxic
masculinity and all this garbage and we
need to make men more feminine that's
not going to make men
it's not going to make the world safer
having a whole bunch of men who give in
to their emotions instantly is going to
create more monsters the reality of
masculinity is controlling your emotions
this is the reality of being a man the
the tenets of masculinity since the dawn
of time have been i was afraid but i did
anyway yeah this is the tenets of
masculine courage
that's what courage is i was afraid to
storm the beaches of normandy but i did
it anyway i was afraid to stay in the
titanic but i did it anyway this is the
whole tenets of masculinity and now
they're saying all of your afraid just
act afraid to be a [ __ ] i'm at a point
now where i'm working for it's pointless
money's fruitless i don't need it but i
can't not do it i have to i don't know
why i am exactly the way i am
because i'm a very happy person but i'm
not content does that make sense i'm
very happy i'm not miserable i'm not
depressed in any way i'm super happy but
also i'm not content there's no quick
fix there is no replication there is no
way you can falsify on a long enough
timeline
so the answer is if you want to be a man
of distinction you need to go and suffer
assurance
one of the only things in this world you
can control is your state of mind you
can't control the weather you can't
control other people you can't even
control your health
one of the very few things in the world
you have genuine control over is your
state of mind you decide if you're a
disciplined person you decide if you're
a happy person you decide if you're an
uh depressed person these are things
that in real time you can affect in your
brain this is all you can control on
earth
if you can't control that
then you're just a feather in the wind
and life's gonna blow you around and you
might land somewhere good you might land
and don't nobody knows
i was a four-time kickboxing world
champion for 12 years i trained five
hours a day six days a week and i was
motivated to train probably about twenty
five percent of the time the rest of the
time i went because i am disciplined